Fill in the table
with whole numbers
to write 430 in
five different ways.
So let's think about
this a little bit.
We could literally view
this 4 as 4 hundreds.
So it's 4 hundreds.
And the 3 is in the tens
place, so it's 3 tens.
So this is 4
hundreds and 3 tens.
But we could rearrange
things a little bit.
For example, we might
only have 3 hundreds.
So we took a hundred
from the hundreds place,
and we could give it
to the tens place.
So if you take that hundred
and give it to the tens place,
a hundred is 10 tens.
So you've got 10 tens, and
then you already had 3 tens.
So you're going to have
13 tens right over here.
Now, this seems a
little confusing.
Remember, this is 430.
This is 300 plus 130.
That's still 430.
Likewise, you could view
this as 200 plus 230.
230 is the same
thing as 23 tens.
Same way, you could view
this as 100 plus 330.
33 tens is 330.
And finally, you could view
it as 0 hundreds and 43 tens.
43 tens is 430.